[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la diplomatie du
vaccin
après la diplomatie des masques elle se
place aujourd'hui au coeur d'une lutte
d'influencé géopolitique où chaque état
producteur de vaccins avance ses pions
alors commencer diplomatie du vaccin
réactifs tels les tensions à
l'international un nouveau scandale
éclate autour de la chine taïwan soutenu
par les états unis l'accusent de mettre
pression sur le honduras et le paraguay
au sujet des livraisons de vaccins
de son côté washington exporte ses
produits principalement vers ses alliés
moscou quant à lui s'efforce de
rattraper ses concurrents
presque soixante dix états ont approuvé
actuellement le vaccin russe entre les
producteurs la concurrence est aussi
brutale la russie accuse les etats-unis
de mettre pression sur le brésil pour le
dissuader d'acheter le vaccin rue de son
côté washington reproche à moscou de
mener une campagne médiatique contre
pfizer et moderna et dévoile ses projets
de distribuer un milliard de doses dans
l'asie du sud-est d'ici 2022 afin d'y et
contrer l'influencé chinoise
cette rivalité et risque de s'accentuer
tant que la distribution équitable des
vaccins ne sera pas assuré le mécanisme
onusien de kovacs peine à décoller parmi
les causes la crise sanitaire en inde
principale productrice des vaccins
d'astrazeneca sur lesquelles compter
justement kovacs
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette compétition acharnée
sur le marché mondial des vaccins anti
qu'ovide c'est le blitz plus de 2
milliards de doses administrées à
travers 180 pays c'est la plus vaste
campagne de vaccination de l'histoire
selon certaines prévisions les dépenses
globales pour les vaccins contre le
comique 19 pourrait atteindre 157
milliards de dollars vers 2025
une véritable manne financière pour
laquelle rivalise aujourd'hui les
laboratoires américains chinois russe ou
encore le suédo britannique astrazeneca
les vaccins américains sont exportés
dans plus de 100 pays se sont modern à
johnson & johnson et l'américano
allemand pfizer pire une tech
la chine a développé quatre vaccins dont
deux ont de fortes positions sur le
marché international sinopharm et
sinovac exporté dans une soixantaine de
pays
la russie a trois vaccins dont le plus
populaire le spoutnik v administrés dans
plus de 40 pays
parmi d'autres producteurs de vaccins
figure le laboratoire suède au
britannique astrazeneca qui produit le
vaccin du même nom utilisé dans plus de
170 pays un chiffre record
il ya aussi la société pharmaceutique
indienne baratte biotech qui produit le
vaccin appelé qu'au vaccin
six pays l'ont déjà administré après la
diplomatie des masques la diplomatie du
vaccin
parmi ceux qui la pratiquent le plus
figure la chine les etats-unis et la
russie tous les trois entendent
améliorer leur image à l'international
et à étendre leur influence en vendant
leurs produits aux pays dans le besoin
pourtant vendre ces vaccins n'est pas
toujours si simple compte tenu d'une
rivalité acharnée sur le marché par
exemple moscou accuse bruxelles de
politiser la question de l'autorisation
de spoutnik v et dénonce aussi les
tentatives de washington de mettre
pression sur certains pays acheteurs du
vaccin russes de leur côté les états
unis qui s'alarment des volumes des
exportations des vaccins chinois est
content
distribué avec l'aide de leurs alliés 1
milliards de vaccins dans l'asie du
sud-est d'ici 2020 de principalement
pour y contrer l'influencé de pékin l'un
des facteurs qui pourraient abaisser la
tension serait le mécanisme onusien
kovacs censé assurer la distribution
équitable des vaccins dans le monde
pourtant deux mois après son lancement
il peine à démarrer
alors comment la diplomatie du vaccin
permettait le principaux fabricants de
promouvoir leurs intérêts comment
rivalis t-il pour l'accès au marché et
enfin quelles perspectives se dessinent
pour ce mécanisme onusien appelé kovacs
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
nous rejoignons un scénic chercheuse
aleris madame séné qui bonjour bonjour
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de cette
diplomatie du vaccin
quelle est la différence selon vous avec
la diplomatie du pétrole des armes etc
la diplomatie est las de ce site
particulier quoi elle se base sur un
précédent on l'année dernière mon avis
établi le vaccin quand comme bien commun
de l'humanité et finalement s'est rendu
compte que ça ne s'est pas passé ainsi
et c'est vrai que là l'autre
problématique c'est que brillante pour
le pétrole qui est une source d'énergie
il ya d'autres possibilités de se
fournir en énergie là sur le vaccin on
est sur un risque vital pour les
populations au niveau de la communauté
mais aussi au niveau individuel il n'y a
pas d'alternative on voit bien on a bien
vu en 2020 que les mesures barrières
seule ne suffisait pas pour limiter les
transmissions virale dont pour casser
les chaînes de transmission et limiter
la propagation de la maladie est autant
relancer l'économie dans un pays où on a
besoin d'un vaccin et donc c'est un
besoin vital c'est ça qui différencie la
la diplomatie du vaccin de la diplomatie
d autres thématiques et comment pourriez
vous définir ces diplomatie des vaccins
justement en quoi elle consiste comment
les pays les étapes producteurs des
vaccins et exerce-t-il aujourd'hui leur
soft power dans ce domaine encore une
fois ça se bat sur le contexte qu'on
vienne
écrire et à côté de ça il ya du coup
c'est payé comme la chine la russie et
cuba l'inde qui ne faisait pas partie
justement de ces pays qui au départ
disait ce sera un bien commun à
l'humanité mais qui ont justement pris
partie de cette communication en disant
nous on l'a pas dit mais on le fait et
justement positionnent leurs pions
diplomatiquement parlant très pertinent
en proposant ou en vendant ça dépend des
pays et ça dépend des contrats établis
au pays qu'il souhaite alors par exemple
la chine a pu faire avec le brésil a un
contrat gagnant gagnant où le brésil
accueillez les les essais cliniques de
stade iii dans sa population contre la
possibilité de recevoir des valses à une
fois ceci après établi mais on sait bien
que la chine a de désintérêt sur sur le
brésil autant au niveau de l'agriculture
avec le soja qui est en forte demande au
niveau de la chine avec le cheptel
porcin est aussi ce qui permet aussi de
construire la nouvelle route de la soie
et lorsqu'on regarde justement tous les
pays qui ont été approchés par la chine
sont des pays stratégiques pour que
justement cuisse tissait se consolider
cette nouvelle route de la soie qui est
la stratégie internationale de la chine
depuis quelques années aussi la russie
également approvisionner ses points par
rapport à l'amérique latine par rapport
au mexique qui est très pertinent
puisque le mexique est en train de
challenge et un petit peu le lead de
l'amérique latine et centrale depuis que
le brésil perd un peu de place sur la
scène internationale donc il ya tout
comme ça des points qui sont très
pertinents et la grande différence avec
ce que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure par
rapport à la géopolitique de l'énergie
ou d'autre chose c'est que comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure c'est une
question aujourd'hui de vie ou de mort
ça fait entrer aussi en jeu la
géopolitique de l'émotion c'est à dire
que les pays vont se souvenir de qui les
a aidés qui ne va pas aider lorsque il a
été question justement de vie ou de mort
et ça c'est quelque chose qui sera qui
restera dans les relations
internationales et dans les relations
plie donc très probablement ça fera
facilité des accords avec les pays qui
ont pu aider
ceux qui en avaient besoin et
compliquera les relations avec ceux qui
ne l'ont pas fait prenons les plus gros
acteurs les états unis et l'union
européenne accuse aujourd'hui la chine
et la russie d'utiliser ses diplomatie
du vaccin pourtant est-ce qu'on peut pas
dire que eux les ruses un peu et qu en
fait chaque pays exportateurs de bac 5
aujourd'hui jouent à ce jeu exactement
des raisons et on le voit aussi de
manière très pertinente avec l'un d'eux
puisque l'inde fournisse et 75% des
vaccins dans le système corex et
lorsqu'ils ont été eux mêmes touchés par
une vague très importante de
contamination ils ont arrêté toute
exportation et garder pour eux leurs
stocks de vaccins pour justement à
limiter la propagation de l'épidémie
et c'est ce qu'on voit partout
finalement si les états unis ont refusé
dans un premier temps de transférer ce
stock de vaccins astrazeneca dont il ne
se servait pas c'était justement pour le
au cas où le au cas où ma population on
a besoin et finalement on se rend compte
que ce soit les états unis que ce soit
la machine que soit la main n'importe
quel pays finalement a pris en
considération en priorité sa propre
population et le contexte international
en deuxième plan et le contexte
international devient possible seulement
lorsqu'on a protégé sa propre population
et c'est ce qu'on voit avec les états
unis où monsieur bah ils donnent ya
quelques semaines un livre on va
travailler en faire à faire en sorte que
cette levée des brevets en termes de
vaccin demandées par l'afrique du sud et
par voilà depuis de nombreux mois soit
possible on va pouvoir vous apporter des
vaccins on va pouvoir
mais tout ça a été possible lorsque le
nombre de contaminations au quotidien
aux états unis même est devenue très
diminué et que la population était
majoritairement vacciner en tous les cas
que l'on n'était pas dans une situation
critique
donc on s'occupe de soi d'abord et
ensuite on va aller voir ce qui se passe
à côté
merci beaucoup madame sénéquier nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons à la fin de
cette émission pour plus de
sur la question merci encore la chine se
retrouve de plus en plus souvent au
centre des scandales internationaux
autour des livraisons de vaccins le plus
récent éclate en mai lorsque le honduras
un des 15 pays qui reconnaissent taiwan
déclare que son gouvernement envisage de
créer un bureau de représentation en
chine afin d'obtenir des vaccins chinois
contre le comique 19 taipei soutenu par
washington place pékin sous le feu des
critiques en l'accusant de profiter de
la crise sanitaire au promouvoir ses
intérêts géopolitiques
en avril le gouvernement taïwanais
dénonce un autre cas supposés de
pression du côté chinois en croire la
diplomatie taïwanaise pékin aurait
promis des vaccins au paraguay allié de
taïwan en amérique latine en échange
d'une dégradation des liens avec taipei
une déclaration aussitôt démentie par
pékin la question taïwanaise n'est
pourtant pas la seule que pékin cherche
sous posément à résoudre grâce à la
diplomatie du vaccin
la révélation faite récemment par le new
york times suggère qu'il y aurait un
lien entre l'aide chinoise au brésil l
entrée de o avait sur le marché de la 5g
dans le pays selon la publication tout
aurait commencé en février avec la
visite du ministre brésilien de la
communication fabio faria en chine après
une rencontre avec des représentants de
la veille ils expriment le besoin du
pays en vaccins saha février la
production de vaccins chinois commencent
au brésil et quelques jours plus tard le
régulateur national autorise ou à veille
à participer au déploiement de la 5g en
changement notable de la ligne politique
du gouvernement brésilien
jusqu'ici sceptique à l'égard du géant
numérique chinois d'une manière plus
globale pourtant la diplomatie du vaccin
est utilisé par pékin comme un élément
de soft power visant à étendre son
influence dans plusieurs régions du
monde
plus de 265 millions de doses expédiées
plusieurs sites de fabrication dans les
pays partenaires
la chine est actuellement le plus gros
exportateur de vaccins au monde
parmi ces consommateurs on compte 2
nombreux pays asiatiques certains états
européens et africains
la quasi totalité de l'amérique latine
est même en état d'océanie
les îles salomon une véritable conquête
du marché vaccinale qui inquiète
d'autres pays producteurs du vaccin sur
tous les états unis mais j'ai tiré que
nous sommes préoccupés par l'utilisation
ou la tentative d'utilisation des
vaccins comme moyen de diplomatie par la
russie et la chine pourtant les états
unis ne manque pas de recourir eux mêmes
alarme diplomatique et alors que pékin
distribuer activement ces vaccins ce
depuis le début de l'année washington se
dépêche pour rattraper le retard
depuis le mois d'avril le président
américain promet de partager 80 millions
de doses avec les pays qui en ont le
plus besoin
les premières 25 millions de connaissent
déjà leurs destinataires 19 millions
seront partagés avec le kovacs et le
reste va être envoyé vers les pays en
crise partenaires et voisins notamment
le canada le mexique l'inde et la corée
du sud
par ailleurs des dizaines de millions de
doses sont déjà envoyé par des
entreprises américaines sous contrat
avec les gouvernements des pays
partenaires
le canada l'australie le japon la corée
du sud et l'union européenne
pourtant certains dirigeants notamment
européen reproche à washington de
freiner l'envoi des vaccins et l'appelle
à lever toutes les restrictions à
l'exportation le gouvernement américain
lui affirme ne pas empêcher les
exportations sauf dans les cas où elles
peuvent nuire à la campagne de
vaccination américaine les fabricants de
vaccins aux états unis sont libres
d'exporter leurs produits tout en
respectant les termes de nos contre 1
notre objectif est de nous assurer que
le peuple américain reçoit le vaccin et
que nous vaccinons le public américain
c'est notre première priorité la
vaccination en interne est d'ailleurs
une priorité dans chaque état producteur
de vaccins
pourtant cela n'empêche pas certains
d'entre eux d'exporter leurs produits
vers les pays dans le besoin
c'est le cas notamment de la russie qui
fait de la diplomatie du bac sans sa
priorité absolue
près de 35 pays ont déjà reçu environ 16
millions de doses du spoutnik v parmi
eux figurent san marin qui aurait
complètement vaincu l'épidémie la
hongrie premiers membres de l'eu avoir
commencé à administrer de spoutnik mais
le considère comme le meilleur vaccin
aujourd'hui budapest se dit ouvert à des
négociations sur une production de ce
vaccin sur son territoire tout comme l'a
fait la serbie je suis fier du fait que
nous ayons pu faire ce travail
je remercie la fédération de russie et
le président poutine pour leurs efforts
nous poursuivrons ces efforts à l'avenir
aujourd'hui le vaccin russe jouit d'une
popularité croissante dans la majeure
partie des pays de l'ancienne urss dans
nombre de pays africains et latino
américains quant au marché européen la
tâche est plus compliqué compte tenu de
l'intransigeance de bruxelles à l'égard
de moscou
[Musique]
la russie et la chine en particulier
continue de promouvoir intensément leur
propre vaccin produit par l'état dans le
monde
elle a dit diplomatie des vaccins est
combiné à des efforts de désinformation
et de manipulation pour saper la
confiance dans les vaccins occidentaux
les institutions de l'union européenne
et les stratégies de vaccination
occidentales européennes
pourtant selon les autorités russes la
situation serait l'inversé spoutnik v
qui serait en réalité victime de la
politisation du processus de vaccination
par lui
comment moscou explique-t-elle ses
positions comment les producteurs de
vaccins étant de thil leur influence
géopolitique quelles mesures pourraient
réduire là rivalités acharnée sur le
marché des vaccins la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
la diplomatie des masques la course au
vaccin enfin la diplomatie du bac 5
quelle sera la prochaine étape de cette
rivalité croissante et comment la
pandémie at-elle raviver les tensions
sur l'échiquier mondial début 2020
inconnu jusqu'ici le nouveau virus sarr
skov 2 détecté à wuhan fin 2019 se
propage à une vitesse alarmante à
travers la chine et s'étend de plus en
plus sur d'autres pays en mars
le coc vite 19 et recensés dans plus de
100 pays l' oms déclare l'état de
pandémie
le même mois la chine arrive pourtant à
contrôler la propagation du virus
largement grâce à un confinement strict
imposé par l'état alors que des dizaines
de pays voir rapidement croître le
nombre de contaminations une crise
sanitaire d'une ampleur sans précédent
réchauffe aussi les tensions sur
l'échiquier mondial
les etats unis accusent la chine d'avoir
dissimulé la gravité de la pandémie à
son début la chine elle commence à
recourir à une diplomatie des masques
qui lui permet à la fois d'améliorer son
image à l'international et de renforcer
la coopération avec certains de ses
partenaires l export du matériel médical
dans plusieurs régions du monde europe
afrique et asie occidentale selon le
ministère du commerce chinois depuis le
début de l'année 2020 pékin a exporté
220 milliards de masques chirurgicaux
après la chine d'autres poids lourds
géopolitique recours aussi à une telle
tactique
par exemple en mars 2020 l'union
européenne envoie 38 millions d'euros au
pays des balkans occidentaux pour
l'achat de matériel médical et de
masques
quant à la russie elle en profite aussi
pour donner un coup de positif à ses
relations avec certains partenaires
elle envoie des équipements médicaux
dans plusieurs pays de l'ancienne urss
en italie aux etats-unis où l'épidémie
fait rage durant l'été le taux
d'infection est en baisse pourtant l'om
s met en garde contre une seconde vague
et déclare que le vaccin anti covit
pourrait assurer la sortie rapide de la
pandémie
s'enclenche la course au vaccin dont
l'enjeu géopolitique scientifique et
économique est énorme
vers le mois de juillet 160 vaccins
candidats sont recensés par l' oms dont
21 passes les essais cliniques sur
l'homme
en août la russie annonce avoir
enregistré son vaccin spoutnik veille
une première mondiale
à peine la déclaration et elle fait
qu'une partie de la communauté
scientifique occidentale et mais un
scepticisme par rapport à la fiabilité
du traitement russe les chercheurs
russes répondent aux préoccupations de
leurs collègues et publié une étude dans
la revue scientifique the lancet
prouvant l'efficacité du vaccin
l'autre objet de critiques du côté des
gouvernements occidentaux et la chine
qui autorise depuis juillet les
inoculations de vaccins expérimentaux
pour les cas urgents et les tests sur sa
population ce qui lui vaut aussi les
foudres d'une partie de la communauté
internationale fin 2020 plusieurs
vaccins sont autorisés par au moins un
pays
le spoutnik vers russe le fader
américano-allemand le moderna américain
l'astra zeneca suédo britannique ou
encore le sinovac chinois en décembre
les campagnes de vaccination commence
dans un certain nombre de pays dans le
monde
la russie et le royaume-uni les
etats-unis l'union européenne et israël
avec le début de la vaccination éclater
la troisième étape de la confrontation
géopolitiques entre les principaux pays
producteurs la diplomatie du vaccin et
les tensions ne font que s'amplifier
aujourd'hui l'exemple des pays comme
israël qui a vacciné presque tout le
monde n'a pas l'air d'avoir une
incidence sur les décisions de bruxelles
le tarde toujours à valider le spoutnik
vais les régulateurs européens n'ont
toujours pas de date précise et pour
moscou c'est le résultat de la
politisation de ce processus yannick
rieu aubigny expire tofu spécialiste je
ne souhaite pas accuser les experts et
les spécialistes de la m
mais nous savons avec certitude que ce
retard est lié à des signaux
correspondant que donne des personnes
haut placées dans l'union européenne
entre temps le vaccin russes se
rencontrent moins d'obstacles en
amérique latine
cependant la pression politique se fait
sentir jusque là ainsi le régulateur
brésilien étudie le spoutnik v depuis
janvier pendant ce temps brasilia très
commandes 10 millions de doses or
l'autorisation se fait attendre moscou y
voient la main des états unis
à mi mars le département de la santé
américain affirme dans son rapport que
son bureau des affaires global à eux
devraient pour persuader le brésil de
renoncer aux vaccins rue
le rapport a depuis disparu du site fin
avril le régulateur brésilien anvisa
refuse en effet d'autoriser le vaccin
russes citant l'insuffisance de données
après un nouvel examen début juin le
vaccin est enfin approuvé
de leur côté les etats-unis accusent
aussi moscou devrait pour discréditer
les vaccins américain ainsi en mars le
département d'état américain accuse la
russie de mener une campagne de
désinformation contre pfizer et moderna
pour disséminer les critiques sur ses
vaccins moscou pourrait utiliser quatre
plateformes en ligne peu connu qui
seraient liés au renseignement russes
des accusations rejetées par le kremlin
qui les qualifie d'absurdité
néanmoins les états unis ne se limite
pas à la guerre médiatique et avancent
leurs pions sur le terrain un asie par
exemple il souhaite contrer l'hégémonie
de vaccins chinois via le format de
couenne alliances régionales entre les
états unis l'inde l'australie et le
japon
le 12 mars le bloc annoncent leur
nouvelle initiative pour livrer les
vaccins à l'asie du sud est
washington et tokyo finances l'inde
s'occupe de la production et l'australie
de la logistique
résultat un milliard de doses pour les
pays de la région vers la fin de 2022 à
titre individuel l'inde tente aussi de
résister à la diplomatie du vaccin
chinoise dans sa zone d'influencé
en février la chine et l'inde propose en
même temps des livraisons de vaccins au
sri lanka traditionnellement plus proche
de new delhi le sri lanka choisi son
offre pour commencer sa campagne de
vaccination scénario similaire au népal
et au bangladesh qui optent tous les
deux pour les doses d'astrazeneca
produit en inde
pourtant cette victoire de new delhi est
de courte durée
face à la vague de nouveaux cas l'inde
suspend les exportations de vaccins pour
accélérer la campagne nationale
immédiatement la chine se précipitent
pour combler le vide
en mai l offre décente
de milliers de doses au sri lanka au
népal et au bangladesh
un exemple classique de la diplomatie du
vaccin qui se répète dans plusieurs
zones du monde
or cette compétition pourrait se calmer
si la répartition des vaccins était plus
équitable selon oxfam
28 % de toutes les doses ont été
administrées dans les pays du g7 contre
seulement 0 3% bhl pour les pays à
faible revenu un des instruments qui
devait égaliser ses distributions était
le programme kovacs officiellement
lancée il ya plus de trois mois où en
est il aujourd'hui
début mars kovacs se féliciter des
premières livraisons accompli au ghana
et en côte d'ivoire
cependant depuis le rythme se ralentit à
ce jour sur plus de 210 millions de
doses prévues seulement 88 millions ont
été livrés en cause principalement la
crise 1 1 de cette pharmacie du monde et
principale productrice des vaccins
d'astrazeneca
facile à transporter à stocker c'est sur
cette marque que kovacs mise et le plus
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
situation où nous ne savons tout
simplement pas quand le lot suivante de
vaccin pourra se matérialiser la
situation sur le marché des vaccins
reste donc tendue ouvrant la voie aux
exercices en diplomatie vaccinale est ce
que cette compétition aide à combattre
la pandémie ou freinent au contraire
c'est plus pour y voir plus clair
nous rejoignons deux nouveaux and
sénéquier chercheuse aleris madame
sénéquier bruxelles ne se pressent pas
d'approuver le vaccin russe selon moscou
ce processus est politisé partagez vous
cette opinion
est-ce que c'est aussi un des aspects de
la diplomatie du vaccin
c'est bien sûr un des aspects de la
diplomatie du vaccin on voit que la
grande majorité des vaccins utilisés en
europe on veut dire la totalité
qu'aliment sont des vaccins occidentaux
il ya eu une grande méfiance par un
membre
de transparence sur les résultats
scientifiques que ce soit du côté de la
chine que ce soit du côté de la russie
ce qui a mis en place une méfiance et on
voit que finalement la méfiance
aujourd'hui dans cette dans ses
campagnes vaccinales sont très
importantes autant au niveau des
institutions qu au niveau des
populations
ce que l'on voit que en europe en ce
moment du fait des effets secondaires
rares équipes au niveau de la sera donné
qu'à on a eu une diminution un petit peu
de popularité sur ce vaccin
donc il ya au niveau des institutions de
la géopolitique très certainement dans
la mesure aussi où pour l'instant les
vaccins arn m en termes de quantité sont
suffisants sur le continent européen
pour vacciner la totalité de la
population à d'ici la fin de l'année
2021 enfin pensez vous que la
répartition non équitable des vaccins
pourrait être une des raisons
principales qui fait que c'est
diplomatie et fonctionne si bien
absolument et c'est je pense que c'est
la raison principale même de pourquoi on
se retrouve aujourd'hui à paris de vieux
politique du vaccin
on a un système kovacs qui est menée par
l'om est entre autres qui avait pour
vocation justement à récupérer tous les
vaccins et les dix pâtissier pour
vacciner la totalité des personnes
vulnérables
en même temps ce qui aurait permis
justement un de limiter le nombre de
décès dans les populations où le virus
circule encore mais aussi de limiter
justement l'émergence de nouveaux de
nouveaux variants seulement ont fait
face aujourd'hui et le fait justement
que les pays ayant les ressources de le
faire est coopté la majorité un des des
doses de vaccin fait qu'aujourd'hui ce
princeps ce corps axe ou même bien
commun de l'humanité qui sont deux
concepts assez similaire n'est pas
possible
est ce que l'on constate aussi c'est que
finalement cette campagne de vaccination
on lui a donné une niveau étatique pour
pouvoir la mettre en place
et c'est là où c'est dommage c'est que
justement toujours et encore on fait
passer
les siens en premier alors c'est humain
mais de la même manière qu'on demande à
un médecin de ne pas traiter sa famille
parce que l'affect est impliqué il
aurait fallu une donnée à l' oms le
pouvoir justement de l'espace et les
vaccins lorsqu'ils y en a besoin le plus
un endroit possible pandémie c'est pas
un virus présents au même endroit
partout sur la planète on l'a vu les
vagues successives en fonction des
régions
et c'est cette impression là qui aurait
été intéressante et pertinente au niveau
sanitaire au niveau économique mais au
niveau humain aussi parce qu'on a un
autre chalet prennent un nouveau
challenge en a un autre challenge qui
nous attend au 21e siècle qu'il va
demander la même coordination une
solidarité entre les états c'est le
changement climatique elle en aura pas
de vaccin merci beaucoup madame scénique
et d'avoir apporté votre éclairage eux
rappelle anne ceni qui est chercheuse
aleris était notre invité aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]